- We're going!
Yeah!
Nina likes to stand on the
bed every time she goes
into a new bedroom.
So, that's our tradition.
I feel like it was a huge
success, this shopping day today.
Right?
Just a huge success.
(object flying and crashing)
(glass breaking)
(thunder rolling)
(chimes ringing)
What's up Believe Nation!
It is time for our, what did you do?
- Peace.
- You got to do it like this.
This is an insult in
Britain, did you know that?
- Oh, I didn't know that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Somebody called me out on
my channel for doing this.
It's insulting in Britain.
So, you got to go this way.
- But this is Chinese cheese.
- Chinese cheese?
- Chinese people do cheese
for photos, stuff like that.
- Side note, we are getting
ready to go to our first,
not our first, nope, it's not our first,
our first 2017 Disney vacation.
It's our fourth year doing this?
- Yeah.
- And we will film every step of the way.
We are leaving tonight with the kids.
It's going to a be a late night flights.
We got to get ready for that.
And Nina's all packed.
- Yeah, I'm all done.
I'm just editing my videos today.
- Go check on her channel.
Evan has no packed, at
all, and he needs to start.
It is, what time?
One.
It's like 12.
12:23, and we're leaving at?
- 5:30.
- It's lots of time.
Lots of time.
Time to pack!
All right, I'm pretty much packed.
I have a tradition of putting
everything in one bag.
So, that's everything.
All my clothes.
My laptop.
Pretty much everything.
We're going to Florida, so
it's going to be pretty light,
so I don't really have to
do a lot of heavy stuff.
You can get on the airplane
with a hoodie and long pants,
and I also carry around my
camera bag, so I can record
what I'm doing.
But there's enough space
at the top here, too,
to be able to put my
camera bag, if I need to.
So, I'm pretty happy with that.
Almost done.
There's one final thing I
need to do before I'm ready
to go.
Get a haircut, 'cause
it's gettin' too long.
Too long!
This is way too long for Florida weather.
It's got to come down.
Right?
- [Nina] No.
- Oh, yeah, oh that's way better.
Oh, yeah.
Now, I'm ready for Florida.
Let's do it.
We are in the elevator.
Nina's fingers.
Everybody's in their cooling hoodies.
Nina's here, I'm here, Hayden's here.
We're going!
Yeah!
Nina has her Mickey, she's excited.
Who's that guy behind?
Here he comes.
- Da-da-da!
Da-da-da-da-da-da!
- [Evan] There he goes.
You have something to say?
- Yeah.
- [Evan] What?
- Who lives in a pineapple under the sea?
SpongeBob SquarePants!
- [Evan] What?
Spongebob?
- Who lives in a pineapple under the sea?
- [Evan] You should be singing.
- SpongeBob SquarePants!
- [Evan] See you, John Carlo.
Look, guys, look, look,
it's snowing outside.
- [Hayden] And all we have is hoodies.
- We don't just have hoodies,
we've got magic hoodies.
Look guys, it's snowing.
We're going to Florida, oh yeah.
(playful organ music)
Oh, look who we picked up.
Look who we picked up.
Jeffery's back.
Stephanie's back.
They're a year taller.
And we're all early.
We're going to get some food?
- [All] Yes!
- We're going to get some food,
and then get on the plane.
Yeah.
What do you want to say, mister?
- Who lives in a pineapple under the sea?
SpongeBob SquarePants.
I don't know the rest of the song.
(playful organ music)
- Hello.
What's your name?
All right, we got settled in.
I got my crispy chicken sandwich.
My favorite.
Nina's got, what do you got, Nina?
He's talking.
- I'm eating.
- [Evan] She got a turkey, bacon club.
Stephanie, what do you got?
- A (mumbling) wrap.
- [Evan] Is it yummy?
Mister?
What do you got?
What are you eating?
- I got a bagel, and it
tastes better than normal.
- [Evan] It tastes better than normal?
All right, Jeffery, what do we got?
(Nina mumbling)
- VGL.
- [Evan] BLT.
- BLT, yeah.
(Evan laughing)
- [Evan] Is it yummy?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Evan] All right, good.
Who's excited to get on the plane?
- [All] Me!
- I have a list.
- [Evan] You have a list?
- First, get on the plane.
We are checking that off on my list.
- Number one is almost done.
Second, go to sleep.
End of list.
Yes!
Great list.
(playful organ music)
All right, we made it on.
It's kind of chaos in here.
Nina did some ninja baggage putting up.
We have bags in five different areas here.
Good job, Nina.
- Thanks.
- Stephanie's next to us here.
And then we got the two
boys on the other side.
- I'm very scared.
(man mumbling)
- Say hi.
- Hi!
- They're going to have a
great sleep on the flight.
We're all very excited about it.
(lullaby music)
(rock music)
All right, it's past midnight.
We arrived.
We got here late because
of the snow in Toronto.
But we're here.
Nina slept a little bit.
Hayden slept, but he's kind of stony now.
There he is.
Stoning it.
We're going to go get our
rental car, and find our place.
(lighthearted acoustic music)
How are you doing, there, Stony Nut?
- Good.
- Yep.
Yes, he is.
He's pretty tired.
Yep, he's tired.
We're going to go get our car rentals.
We're going to go outside.
It's warm, but it's not crazy hot.
Where's the snow, guys?
All I see is palm trees.
Yeah.
- [Hayden] And nice, warm air.
- And a nice, warm what?
Air.
Yeah.
- And smoke.
Well, you get that at the airport, too.
Okay, so it's 1:40, 1:40 a.m.
We couldn't figure out
how to turn our data on,
and then we got lost.
And then, we stopped at
Walgreens to get some cereal
for tomorrow and something for me to eat,
'cause I'm hungry.
We are tired.
Kids are gettin' ready for bed.
This is Nina, I'm here with her.
- It's a nice place.
We'll let you guys in on
what's happening tomorrow.
We're going to get ready for bed, rest up.
Tomorrow's shopping day,
so it should be exciting.
Nina's tryna, we're
locked out of our bedroom,
that's amazing.
(Nina mumbling)
Oh, there you go.
How's the bedroom look?
We'll show you the bedroom.
Nina likes to stand on the
bed every time she goes
into a new bedroom.
So, that's our tradition.
Don't fall.
Have a great night, guys.
We'll see you in the morning.
- Goodnight.
- All right!
Happy day one!
- Day one!
Day one.
- Day one.
- One.
- Nina and I went to sleep at--
- Hayden!
- Four.
4:00 a.m., 'cause it was
a time change, as well.
And it is, what time is it now?
- It's just.
(object crashing)
- 12:10.
- Hayden, your hat is a weapon.
Hat's a weapon.
We're eating breakfast.
We're in our Airbnb.
And then, we're going
to get ready to go out.
Do some shopping.
- Uh-huh.
And do Pokemon.
- And maybe do some Pokemon.
(mumbling)
- What do I press?
- We'll see what happens.
Yum.
All right, we're outside.
It is hot, and we like it.
We're looking for geckos.
- [Hayden] Oh, there it is!
Oh, is that a gecko?
- No, that's, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it's a gecko.
- [Evan] Kid, nobody move.
- [Hayden] Mini.
- [Evan] There it is.
So, today is shopping day.
We're going to go get Nina some stuff.
What do you think, Nina?
- Yes.
- What are you hopin' to find?
- I don't know.
Nothing.
- Nothing.
Well, if you're hoping
to find nothing, I think
you're in luck.
I think we'll find nothing.
The kids are in the back.
What are you guys doing?
- [Nina] Stephanie's teaching him.
- I'm teaching Hayden
how to tie his shoes.
- Tie a shoe, tie a shoe.
- Oh, Hayden's learnings to tie his shoe.
I love it.
Good job, let's go!
We found the salsa station.
Da-da-da-da-da,
da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da,
let's see some body waves, Nina!
(Nina laughing)
Woo!
(salsa music)
All right, we made our first stop.
Malls at Millennium.
Hayden's very excited, Jeffery's,
just punched me in the
face on that jump, Jeffery!
Nina's going to discipline.
- No.
- That's life.
Life sometimes punches you in the face.
And you keep going.
That's how we roll.
Believe.
(whimsical synthesizer music)
First stop of the day has
to be Starbucks, right?
Has to be Starbucks.
I see one ahead.
Let's see it, mister.
Oh!
Good job, mister.
We're here at Microsoft again.
Maybe this, third time's a charm.
I think he's going to try again.
Let's see.
It's Nina's turn.
Yay!
Third time.
It's my third time here.
(mumbling)
- There are three levels.
I told her I only want to do one level.
- [Evan] Which one, archery?
- Yeah.
- [Evan] Or the drawing?
Or the whales?
- I just want to do,
I just want to try it.
- [Evan] You just want to see it.
- Yeah.
- [Evan] Okay.
Nina's excited.
(daunting music)
Go, Nina, go!
Nina, they're going to kill you!
Oh, wow, what happened there?
The pizza has arrived.
- [Stephanie] Thank God.
- Pizza!
- [Evan] Let's open it up.
- [Stephanie] I need a slice
of pizza to keep me cool.
- [All] Oh!
- [Nina] Hayden, plates.
Oh, it's hot.
- [Evan] Hayden doesn't want any anymore.
- [Nina] It's hot Hayden, so you can wait.
- [Jeffery] I feel alive.
- [Evan] Nina lost all of the cheese.
Okay, is that Hayden's piece?
With no cheese?
(laughing)
- [Nina] I'll go get a fork.
- [Jeffery] It's very hot.
- What, yuck?
You don't like mushrooms?
All right, well we have
two whole pizzas to eat.
Here we go.
(fun chime music)
All right, we're done.
We're leaving one mall.
Nina bought--
- Sephora!
- Just basically the same thing.
We spent half the time, I
think, at the Microsoft store.
To do what we did.
We're all, how full are we?
- Very.
- Very full.
We ate two extra-large pizzas
between the five of us.
- Three kids.
- Three kids and Nina.
Nina had the biggest slice at the end.
That was pretty epic.
- Did you?
- She did, she had the biggest slice.
You spat on yourself?
- 'Cause you picked a
small one, you even ate.
- Nina, don't spit on yourself.
Okay, we're going to get in
the car and go to another.
This is a regular mall.
We're going to go to an
outlet mall for Nina.
- [Hayden] What's an outlet?
- Outlet mall.
- [Hayden] What's that?
- It's a mall with lots of outlets.
(Nina laughing)
- [Hayden] What?
- Here we go!
(upbeat acoustic music)
Here it comes, ready guys?
♫ My name's Blurry Face
♫ And I care what you think
All right, all right,
all right, we made it.
After some chaos in the parking lot,
we are going to the Premium Outlet Mall.
The Vineland Premium Outlet
Mall, where Nina is going
to buy something.
- Woo-hoo!
- [Evan] What are we hoping to find, Nina?
- Oh, I don't know.
- [Evan] Shoes.
- We're hoping to find a toy for Hayden.
- A toy for Hayden?
No.
- [Jeffery] A toy for me, too.
- No.
Jeffery, toy, no.
- [Jeffery] Yes!
- No, it's Nina day.
We're here to find something
for Nina 'cause we love her,
she's special, and she
deals with all of us.
- What?
- Right, you got to love Nina.
(upbeat piano music)
- You like it?
Do you like it?
I don't know.
(singing in a foreign language)
- We're waiting for the girls to come out.
(mid tempo guitar music)
- We're heading back.
Nina didn't buy anything else.
- It's okay.
- That was it.
Just a Sephora, what did you buy again?
- Nothing.
The eyeliner, and a primer.
- Eyeliner.
And primer.
I kind of feel like that
was an insane eyeliner.
(Nina laughing)
I feel like that was
maybe worth the whole trip
to come to Florida.
- Just to buy eyeliner.
- To buy the eyeliner.
I feel like it was a huge
success, the shopping day today.
Right?
Just a huge success.
It's like if that's all
we got for the whole week,
it was a big win.
(chuckling)
Okay, back to the car.
Get some grocery shopping done.
- Yeah.
- And then go home.
- Yeah!
(acoustic music)
It's time to do everybody's
favorite part of the whole trip.
Grocery shopping!
- No!
- Yeah!
Let's buy some food.
(exciting music)
- Protein bars are yummy,
and I wish I could have
a protein bar.
- [Evan] Nina.
- This is for you.
- [Evan] This is a lot
of food for one week.
Let's pop it on.
- Let's pop it, ah!
Chocolate milk!
- Almond milk, almond milk.
(mumbling)
- They're buy one get one free.
- [Evan] Buy one Nina, get one free.
- If you could find a second Nina.
- [Evan] Nina's one of a kind, okay.
It doesn't exist.
Wow, that's a lot of
food for one week, Nina.
- It's not a lot of food.
- [Evan] It's not a lot of food.
- Just the package.
- [Evan] Just the bare essentials.
Some Stella, some wine.
It's just a package.
It's a lot of stuff.
- Oh, watch.
- No, it's not a lot of stuff.
It's a big package with nothing inside.
Is what you're saying?
You're the opposite.
You're a lot of stuff in a little package.
Okay?
We love you.
We made it home!
(singing)
Yeah.
Time to pack up the food
inside and eat some dinner!
- I got dinner right in my hands.
- Uh, that's breakfast tomorrow, mister.
We're not having Cheerios for dinner.
I might have some later.
- [Hayden] Get in the house!
- Not for the kids.
- [Hayden] Before!
- [Evan] All right, Nina's
cooking us some yummy food.
What do we have, Nina?
- Food.
Potatoes.
- [Evan] Some yummy
potatoes, look at that.
- [Nina] Some beans.
- [Evan] Green beans, nice, and?
Oh, yeah, look at that.
Steak strips.
What inspired this, Nina?
- I don't know.
- [Evan] You were hungry for steak?
- No, just whatever I feel like.
- What you felt like.
All right!
Dinner time!
So, that's the end of day one.
Realized I forgot to make a video.
We had an awesome dinner,
and then just put the kids
to bed, and chilled on the couch.
Watched some Shark Tank, had some beer.
Yeah, time to catch up on some sleep,
because we didn't sleep
that well yesterday.
Wake up and go to the baseball game.
Woo!
Go, Jays, go!
Thank you guys for joining us for day one.
Let's hope for an amazing day
two, and a Blue Jays victory.
Good night.
(object flying and crashing)